je prie monsieur andrieu de s'excuser
d'avoir dans son journal menti pendant
cinq jours au sujet de sa vie celui de
mon sujet du coup la
jeunesse et la sueur des analystes
donnait le droit mais jury et je vous en
prie mais vous me traitez de flics vous
m'élisez nous qui m'a doublé nous étions
c'est vous qui l'avez
vous êtes cela car je m'excuse si
c'était vous n'avez pas que tu ne manges
dans sexus vous n'avez pas tous les deux
la paranoïa du débat
je pense que nous partirons ensemble à
leur mort n'ont pas vraiment dommage que
toutes ces ententes de jaurès on
entendra enfin les réfugiés
naturellement que non bien sûr si l'on
reste la même sur a brillé vous restez
je ne reste pas en partiront individus
ah ben voilà c'est la démocratie